welcome to waters world I'm Jessie
waters cause and effect that is a
subject of tonight's waters words if a
tree falls in the forest and no one's
around does it make a sound the same
question can be asked about President
Trump success if the media doesn't
report it will anybody hear about it
they will on the show when the Donald
speaks or takes action the media
immediately criticizes him but they
never give him credit when his words or
actions create a positive result take a
look at what happened on trade President
Trump started slapping tariffs on steel
and aluminum imports the media went nuts
but you just saw at the White House the
result of chaos confusion and also some
presidential conviction and now new
tariffs that might ultimately might
ultimately ignite a trade war president
has disregarded the advice of most
business leaders how many of those core
makers may just decide you know what we
will go to Mexico and sell our cars if
you're thinking by now that this smacks
of a president who hasn't really thought
this through very well well that's
exactly how it happened but the tariffs
were just a bargaining chip and they
worked just this week we secured a
wonderful deal with South Korea we were
in a deal that was a horror show it was
going to produce 200,000 jobs and it did
for them that was a Hillary Clinton
special I hate to say
this will produce 200,000 jobs she was
right but it was for them it wasn't for
us so we've redone it this week South
Korea doubled the amount of American
cars it would allow to be sold in their
country great news for the American
workers in Michigan and South Korea
would have to limited steel exports in
America by 30% this in exchange for
Trump temporarily dropping the threat of
steel tariffs The Washington Post
reported quote it marks the first
successful renegotiation of a trade deal
for the Trump administration by the way
that line was buried near the bottom of
the story not even worthy of a headline
turning to China after the fire and fury
threats against North Korea and 60
billion in tariffs slapped on Chinese
exports little rocket man traveled to
Beijing for constructive talks with his
puppet master America and North Korea
are now hopefully on the cusp of
historic talks that could lead the peace
on the peninsula but moving along very
nicely with North Korea we'll see what
happens
certainly the rhetoric has calmed down
just a little bit would you say would
you say and we'll see how it all turns
out maybe it'll be good and maybe it
won't and if it's no good we're walking
and here at home more good news for the
American worker as a result of the Trump
administration's tax and regulation
cutting Americans filing for
unemployment benefits fell to the lowest
level since 1973 that's almost half a
century ago and the unemployment rate is
the lowest it's been since 2000 remember
when the media said the Trump tax cut
wouldn't help the little guy McDonald's
just announced it would spend a hundred
and fifty million dollars on college
tuition for thousands of its fast-food
employees thanks to the corporate tax
cut and that's a McFlurry of good news